what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today from new rock stars the Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 trailer Easter eggs
breakdowns details you missed leave a
like if you haven't seen our trailer
reaction to the Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. go ahead check it out let's see
what's going on
welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer regarding the Galaxy vol 3 and
it's really hard to know where to start
crying first and Rocket's backstory and
Rockets that are gonna happen in this
movie let's break down this trailer
frame by frame the Marvel Studios title
card cross dissolves into Peter Quill's
tape deck the letters bearing the
stripes of the labels of the past
awesome mixed tapes that Peter's mother
Meredith quill left him but remember the
second of which was destroyed along with
Peter's Walkman by ego in Guardians
volume 2. the tape deck of the ship is
still okay though at least we think it
is their [ __ ] by the way is now the
Bowie which we learned of in the
Guardians holiday special the Bowie is a
three-story ship that replaces the
Benetar which was their ship in Infinity
war end game and Thor 11 Thunder and
that replaced their original membership
of the Milano Bowie is an appropriate
name for the ship David Bowie's moonage
Daydream did play in that awesome mix
vol 1 as the Guardians first arrived
into nowhere in the 21st yes yes yes
there's nowhere by the way is now their
home base after they bought it from The
Collector but over the tape deck here
the needle flips back and forth and
particles float in front of the logo
maybe dust or snow not really sure but
it makes me really worried that the
ship's inside could have been exposed to
the zero gravity of space would that
sound needle Thanos found in space I
mean can we test this please but don't
send a dog to do it all right Pete Leica
pretty sure she's a stylistic choice for
the needle no that's in the actual scene
yeah Marvel Studios is floating out in
space in an open ship and everyone's
been sucked out after She-Hulk you never
know now you never know and Kevin sent
everybody up and just cleaned house
Peter man's the bridge of the Bowie no
one else in the seats and he and the
other Guardians wear new uniforms in
this movie inspired by the blue and red
uniform the Abnet landing area of the
comics it's somewhat reminiscent of the
novacor uniform the Nova core would
likely still be in shambles after Thanos
wrecked xandar to get the power Stone so
the Guardians really have taken on the
role of Galactic First Responders some
might say guardians of it the Bowie
soars in this planet Universe looks like
New York of Earth but it totally is not
there's something that looks like the
Statue of Liberty front and center there
but Liberty Island doesn't really face
in that direction the terrain is all
different the cityscape behind it is 100
not Manhattan New York and New Jersey
and also the creatures they bump into
yeah that statue has to have an animal
has shipping cranes and a cruise liner
there's a few triangular structures
along the water that remind me a lot of
the Sydney Opera house when you look at
it from that angle I I think what we are
looking at here is a replica Earth a
combination of two Marvel settings one
the high evolutionaries counter Earth
from the comics this is a pure all right
that's pretty cool places a micro second
out of dimensional sync to hide it from
Earth I know I know awesome but I think
we're also looking at a version of half
world that is Rocket's origin Planet
listed on its xandar booking screen in
the 2014 film so I think the high
evolutionary created this place as a
home for his Creations the new Men new
men in the comics are humanoid
animalistic bipedal hybrids so really
when we get closer to that Statue of
Liberty I suspect it's going to be a
Planet of the Apes scenario not the 60s
Charlton Heston Statue of Liberty but
really the 2000 Timber Lincoln
memorialistic base wow that actually
leads it up to an interesting plot point
that could occur maybe instead of Rocket
dying he decides to stay on this planet
with people he considers to be his
people in the end you know he actually
finds his family and and two I don't
know if this is a product of the high
evolutionaries work that'll give him a
solid cause to defend them from well
well also Rocket's not with them in that
moment so maybe Rocket's already been
taken by this point in the opening of
the trailer makes you think this might
be early on in the movie but maybe it's
already post rocket being held hostage
in some capacity by high evolutionary or
maybe they think he's being held hostage
and then it's a joke and he's just there
visiting
having fun
you got good jokes today I got great
jokes Guardians of the Galaxy gotta read
the best jokes who knows maybe Herbert
Windham bashes himself a Kang and makes
a huge statue of himself but yes the
high evolutionary who is he he is
Herbert Windham he's going to be played
in this movie by actor Chuck Woody oichi
in the comics The evolutionary is an
associate of Mr Sinister Nathaniel Essex
and X-Men villain but Windham is
Marvel's Ultimate geneticist he's known
for experimenting on various life forms
and he breeds these Animal Human hybrids
that he calls the new men and I think
this is what rocket and his old
girlfriend Lila will be revealed to be
in the MCU the Bowie ships colors match
the code trans allegory right in the
middle of the suburb barely missing
crushing a few houses though definitely
ruining a few Lawns there notice though
that all the cars and clothes are from
the 1980s the 80s aesthetic will be a
big thing in this movie Peter Quill was
abducted in the year 1988 so all of his
interests are stuck in the 80s also
James Gunn has said that his awesome mix
vol 3 has already been decided and it's
mostly going to be 80s songs he's known
for writing tracklists actually into a
script because usually all of his songs
have a diegetic role in the narrative so
why the 80s well I wonder if Wyndham's
move to create the Newman Newman and
counter Earth half world could have come
out of a survivalist Panic that many
felt in the 1980s during that cold war
brickmanship when everyone was super
anxious that the world was gonna nuke
itself so maybe in that Panic a super
brilliant but always overthinking things
Herbie was like fine damn yourselves out
of hell i'll build another Earth and
I'll populate it with my animal people
and the 80s will live on forever there's
also like serial killers and is
so there was a lot more than the Cold
War 80 sucks it was a terrible time it
was a terrible time and everybody needed
finally on the 80s
it was really fearful time in the 80s
that's why there was such good fiction
because everyone wanted to escape and
stay that way okay as the Guardians de
board the Boeing notice it's just Peter
mantis nebula Drax in swole Groot no
Gamora yet and no rocket I think they
have come here looking for Rocket who
maybe went looking for his home world
and his old friends the locals are all
suspicious one is carrying a fly swatter
really the longer you look at these guys
the freakier they get like the postal
worker looks like a bird maybe a peacock
but has five humanoid fingers that are
Talon claws I also just like the idea in
this world male still might be delivered
by birds even birds that don't fly
because they don't have wings but they
still just walk and drive around the guy
who shouted him is a rabbit whose ears
are now drooped down like long hair of a
professor and behind him there's another
bird beaked man but with hair like the
Muppet Bert there's also a panda and a
polo shirt into jeans jeans held up by a
belt I hope that belt isn't made of
leather now that street sign has some
alien language on it it's kind of hard
to make out but it's another indicator
that this isn't like uh
there's another planet that was created
to be an alien world like notice how
they all speak in another language
Drax pegs this poor kid with a kickball
that sound is really seared in my memory
from all my Years playing Jim dodgeball
really I'm less worried about the ball
hitting her face than I am by that
girl's head hitting the pavement
such a funny moment reaction is
surprising considering bullets tickled
him in the Guardians holiday special
also notice how small inconsistency
right in the head the music in this
trailer is spacehogs in the meantime
from 1995. it's a glam rock hit from
their album resident alien they were
heavily influenced by David Bowie
actually that
but the beginning was his influenced by
the dial tone one would hear when you
make a call from the U.S to the UK and
you get a cross line the lead singer
said it's the sound of a phone ringing
and being engaged at the same time the
lead singer Royston Langdon said that
this song in general is him trying to
reach people find an end to isolation it
reminds us a lot of rocket in this movie
someone who is desperate to reconnect to
his roots but the timing just not really
connecting we see that Peter has his
headphones in remember since he goes
beautiful I assume this is the Zune that
yondu left him at the end of volume 2
and all the music we hear in this movie
is going to be messages
says don't forget about where we came
from and we learned the holiday special
that mantis is Peter's half-sister both
of them children of ego who is a
Celestial this ancestry will likely play
a big role in the story what does it
mean for them to have Celestial DNA
especially now that we know more about
celestials after the Eternal spill why
did that DNA pass on to Peter and Peter
was able to activate it while so many
other of ego's Offspring died also a
reminder to everyone that James Gunn's
long lost hidden Easter egg from the
Guardians movies is still undiscovered
word but likely has something to do with
Meredith quill and all those location
coordinates that we see throughout the
films James Gunn has said over the years
that new rock stars and Mt who's really
the pioneer of trying to decode this
stuff and various others online have
gotten close to uncovering it fully but
not all the way yet ultimately I think
it's gonna be all about Meredith will
and what about her DNA made Peter Quill
so uniquely successful to carry the
celestial DNA from higo and I think
mantis as the external hard drive of all
of ego's guilt might know more about
that secret from Meredith because ego
was the one who gave Meredith quilled
that brain tumor oh so there's got to be
some like major combination of powers by
the end of this movie that they actually
unleash right yeah definitely I mean if
they're going to be doing that and
setting all this up that's where it has
to go yeah it'd be given everything
we've seen up until now and whatever
residue is left over from the Power
Stone experience and all that stuff and
then their Newfound Bond as siblings
like maybe that'll also factor in like I
don't know maybe they need each other to
fully like wake up the latent breadth of
power they can both wield or something
they'll be the Wonder Twins I'm just
excited to see if James Gunn after
Guardians 3 comes out if he'll actually
finally unveil what the hell this Easter
egg is I've already lost interest James
I look I'm over Easter over it now and
uh by this point is anyone really gonna
care about this Easter egg don't worry
this better be the most down the line
blowing Easter egg of all time it'll be
a silly silly silly joke so we see babe
cage is a hand
rocket have siblings that he doesn't
know about I assume this is the hand of
Herbert Wyndham before Herbert
cybernetically experiments on Rocket to
give him intelligence this matches the
footage from the Comic-Con trailer that
showed a close-up of a pen writing 89p
13 which was the number on Rocket's
booking screen on xandar in the first
film we say God damn that's attention of
detail spacesuit's looking like those
from the Among Us game now in reality
these are actually not to the red yellow
and blue spacesuits in 2001 A Space
Odyssey one of two references to
Kubrick's classic in this trailer I want
to say during the trailer review I said
this was a nod to 2001 A Space Odyssey
and everyone was saying Among Us and you
say gorillas well which I've never been
even seen 2001 A Space Odyssey yeah and
I'm sure the gorilla's video is just
true beatings 2001 A Space Odyssey so
you are the rightest one of us and I'm
the rightest one and I cannot wait for
your 2001 reactions
try to be smart John I was just noting a
nerdy parallel and the fact that they're
like jumping around and they're doing
more fun stuff than in space they the
Guardians are like the gorillas they
just don't play music people don't don't
pay attention those trailer reviews
comments you don't know what you're
talking about morons they're all morons
that's how I ostracize the entire
audience base of the rejected oh y'all
morons could also say we got five six
infinity stone colors here minus a
purple one for the Power Stone later we
see that it's Peter in the yellow suit
mine Stone mantis in the orange suit
Soul Stone Drax and the red suit reality
Stone and then nebula and Gamora are in
the green and blue suits so you know
time and space I don't know if there's
any connection there the groups I think
they're just themed to their character
colors
with six rainbow colors on it really
what is this massive fleshy structure
that they're leaping down onto we get a
better look at it later throughout the
trailer you can see this flesh has hairs
poking out of it as they jump across it
I speculate this could be spinal or
nerve tissue from the rest of nowhere's
body that ringed hole with the
construction and it could actually be
nowhere's eyes optical nerve upon we
slow it down definitely or maybe even
after he was beheaded Gamora looks at a
Polaroid not sure what of yet maybe
something Peter gave her to try to
remind her of his years with the
original 616 Gamora we know that the
Comic-Con footage that Gamora will be
leading a side group of ravagers the
Guardians March through the streets of
nowhere that's the same set that we saw
in the Guardians holidays that's mantis
Drax rocket is sipping something and
then nebula is carrying Peter then we
see Groot and craglin and Cosmo the
space dog now Cosmo was reintroduced in
the holiday special first scene as one
of the collector's items in the 2014
film Cosmo is based on Leica the poor
Russian space dog thus the Soviet
letters on their spacesuit and the
comics Cosmo has telepathic and
telekinetic Powers we saw a little bit
of that in the holiday special but the
dog now has voice caller that's voiced
by actress Maria bakalova that was the
actress in Borat 2.
of the Guardians and Cracklin did say in
the holiday special that he learned
about what Christmas was from Cosmo who
learned it from rocket I could totally
see something happening in the most
unexpected way where someone on the team
maybe cragland that looks like their
life is on the line because I feel like
James Gunn's gonna have scenes toying
with the audience like is this character
about to die is his character about to
die and then Cosmo steps in maybe
levitates or pushes something away or
just have a crazy telepathic blasting we
don't see Cosmos doing it and then the
camera turns over and then you see that
it's Cosmos and then there's like a
record scratch
sound
what because of Comedy
sort of
you know you sort of pan over to the dog
the dog goes
except in a Russian
[Laughter]
touching himself
nebula is it can't be that bad snot
Groot so nebula's got some impressive
strength James gonna suggested that
nebula is now more of an authority
figure of nowhere remember that she and
Rocket are older than the rest of them
because nebula and Rocket survived the
blip and lived all during those five
years rocket loads of business after the
fight with Adam Warlock the right of him
that is gamora's hand so she has joined
up with them at this point there's also
this other four-legged creature on the
ground in the background on the right we
see that same thing trotting behind all
of them in this later shot in this
trailer reminds me a lot of Morris from
chongqi but remember Morris had six legs
so I don't know this could just be
another one of windham's lab experiments
we all fall in love with and buy plush
toys up we see Herbert Windows not
evolutionary as this woman jogs in a
ring around him reminding us of that
jogging scene in 2001 A Space Odyssey
Windham Citadel is dark Sleek menacing
reminding us of he who remains Citadel
and Loki but without all those kinsugi
crack patterns Gamora and mantis help
Drax who's been shot in the chest as
Peter holds nebula behind them I assume
this is the bright white interior of the
glowing white inside of that fleshy
structure that we saw earlier notice how
similar pink matter is covering the
surfaces inside of here spherical object
I don't really know what it is or what
the hell is going on in all these shots
but there are people in other similar
suits floating around them but their
suits have a lot more nodes on their
limbs and on their backs and the guards
like they're attached to it then the
shot of the Bowie crashing through this
barrier now compared to the shots that
we've seen of ships jumping through the
hexagonal U and T end and the MCU this
looks far more chaotic like either the
untn didn't open properly for them or
they met some barrier that they had to
force their way through if we are
looking at counter Earth this could be
them forcing their way through some
dimensional riff okay rocket is in rough
shape he's lying on this grate that's
covered in debris there are new scars on
his face revealing the cybernetic layers
beneath and he says we'll all fly away
together one last time into the forever
and beautiful sky oh my God many are
speculating that rocket will die in this
movie and I guess that's possible I just
think that would be too obvious of a
conclusion to draw from this trailer
this lead it could be a surprise they're
doing a really bad job hiding it but I
don't know if we're looking at his death
scene here like notice that rocket does
not seem to be wearing anything here and
other than brought into the Kiln prison
rocket is almost always wearing clothes
so I think what we could be looking at
here is a flashback to Rocket's earlier
days when he was windham's lab
experiment he's either lying on the base
of his cage here or he's in the process
of an escape attempt either way talking
to someone like Lila across the bars
trying to instill hope and her and all
the other hybrids that they might be
able to escape together someday and I
feel like if anyone's gonna bite the
bullet I feel like it would be Drax just
because Dave Bautista I feel like wants
to put an end to all this sure but if
they do kill rocket I love rocket I
really do I do think if they kill rocket
though they gotta do it Glenn Style
Walking Dead you know what I mean yeah I
think High evolutionary he's got a bash
Rockets just like a really standing
around the Guardians you don't know
which one the high evolutionary is going
to kill he does Drax just to make you
think it's over easy yeah they're like
okay that we saw and yeah bam smashes
that raccoon's head in like nothing for
like five straight minutes yeah just
literally Lila's there she's watching
the cosmos was the most disturbing part
and it's and it's going to be funny
though it's going to be funny yeah yeah
it's like it's gonna be ironic how long
yeah this is gonna be a cool needle drop
right after I think rocket up until this
point
side first thing he tackles where's
white boots and a white trench coat and
other people dress this way lie nearby
on the ground they're all they're
scientists cybernetic implant heads like
what nebula has but with yellowish skin
the sky and brown below actually match
the terrain of that maybe counter Earth
maybe half World location
I think this is a high evolutionary's
castle or his floating base and these
white dress people are The Enclave The
Enclave in the comics is the cult of
scientists who create Adam Warlock and I
think in this movie The Enclave will be
the ones who supplied Aisha with Adam
warlock's cocoon in the comments Adam
Warlock leaves The Enclave he flies into
space and he runs into the high
evolutionary who gives him the name
warlock then after that he meets The
Universal Church of Truth who worship
him but I think this group here is The
Enclave in in this movie they're going
to be windham's group of genetic
scientists in volume 2 yandu referred to
the scientists that made rocket I think
these are the scientists also I think
there's a parallel here with windham's
look Windham is also bald and has
cybernetic plugs in the back of his head
I think this movie is just going to
simplify everything to have Adam Warlock
be a creation of her win who leads the
enclave and by the way though we do not
see them in this trailer both Elizabeth
Debicki and Sylvester Stallone are
credited Among Us cast at the end of the
trailer so we can't expect to see both
Aisha Aisha will return remember is the
leader of the ravagers I wonder if that
scene when he tackles because it looks
like Pete quill is getting pretty
aggressive in this movie if that
actually occurs after that moment in the
trailer where you see quill like
screaming and Agony at the top of his
lungs overlooking something oh yeah
because it looks like it's in some type
of lab room so imagine he's taking it
out on the scientists if he's gonna go
that far to like tackle someone out of
the window you know yeah maybe it's not
necessarily the throes of like intense
pain as much as it is like that last bit
of effort you need to charge somebody or
something like that yeah be cathartic
will and Groot flee the crashing Bowie
ship nebula cheers in a celebration
among the other refugees of nowhere then
her Wyndham looks barely disappointed in
that same Hangar Bay that we saw the
Guardians in before the one that was on
fire debris flies around him looking a
lot like the dust that appeared over the
Marvel Studios logo in the opening shot
then a close-up of a drop of blood and
then Peter Wales and Agony over what I
assume is an operating table with a
breathing tube someone dying in front of
him so who dies in this movie if the
blood drop is from this scene it's
probably not Groot here because you know
Groot doesn't really bleed like we do
also we already got a group Death in the
first movie so yeah we could be looking
at Rocket I just don't think that
earlier shot is from its death scene
specifically but it could be someone
else notice the shot rocket is hugging
this trash otter this is Lila I just met
you LOL
in the comics Lila is Rocket's soulmate
from half world and the Aristotle
company but notice here she has
cybernetic pause really a clamp on each
hand but in the shot where he hugs her
rocket again is not wearing clothes his
head is a bit smaller behind them in
this location are a bunch of other cages
so yeah this is a flashback probably the
moment they escaped and when they parted
ways so will Lila reunite with rocket in
the present did she make it also who do
we think will voice Lila maybe Daniela
melchior who has been confirmed to play
some small unknown roles with James Gunn
on the suicide squads who played rat
catcher 2. others have wondered since
she didn't play Bradley Cooper's lover
and A Star is Born I don't know about
that
better blood dropping what is it
dropping bro is that a hook is that the
edge of Lila's hand clamp you should
think about it the saddest option for
who could die in the scene with quill
screaming could just be Lila and all of
them are sad because they know how
important Lila is to Rock It mantis
nebula and Drax run into Annapolis
remember these were the interdimensional
squid monsters I cut it out of the video
I wasn't sure I thought you were right
yeah
warlock in the comics having one of the
Infinity Stones The Soul Stone in his
forehead a trait that the MCU instead
gave to Vision with a mind Stone Holter
has described Adam Warlock as a
character with a newborn infantile mind
while Vision minted ironically Adam
really was born yesterday and he shows
it he gives nebula the scut Farkas
treatment nebula appears to be wearing
some kind of chainmail armor that covers
her arm you can see that catwalk Bridge
of nowhere in the background it seems
like Adam has tracked the Guardians down
to Nowhere mantis sobs in a location
with the same lighting as a place where
Peter cries remember she is an emotional
empath her sorrow is likely to be
heightened in this moment as she's gonna
be feeling the grief of all the
survivors here I mean it looks like
she's in the same room where Peter was
in agony yeah so Peter's dead and she's
agonizing over him yeah and Peter is
looking over his dead body yeah it's
just a chain
he's like why can't I make no expression
at movie it's gonna be an artist
ethereal for Guardian history on people
going I don't get it
really abstract Marvel don't play it
that outside the box cheese rocket is
seen in a white glowing realm that looks
like an ethereal version of that
cage-filled lab you can see the outline
of the cages behind him he's once again
not wearing clothes and his cybernetic
bolts are visible on his chest so maybe
rocket is flatlined or he's close to
death and his mind is transporting him
back to the place where he met Lila and
speaking of characters dying swole Groot
says we are Groot which is Father OG
group only said as his final words when
he gave up his life all of the times
Groot just makes the sound I am Groot
with subtle vocal and tonal variances on
that which is where the different words
come in Peter and Groot are in a
shootout with those Enclave folks and
their soldiers I think this shot is
coming right before Peter tackles one of
them out the window now watching the
Guardians holiday special a lot of folks
were freaked out by swole groot's form
but now you can see it serves a
practical purpose there's just a bunch
of extra limbs and branches tucked in
there ready to clutch multiple things at
once and I love what we cut to Black
right as Groot shoots the camera the
title reveal translates from Cree
letters to English as it illuminates in
the Comic-Con trailer we actually saw
nebula putting up this sign so this
might be an actual sign in the movie
that gets set up on nowhere onto the
final clip kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad yes the one stupid guy who
No One Love sounds like Herbert Windham
the idea that no one loves him suggests
that Herbie had to create his new men
because no one else would love him like
Michael Scott wanted 100 kids so we can
have 100 friends and no one can say no
to be in his friend like mantis luxury
dranks against killing cops in the
holiday special Drax restraining himself
from using deadly force will be a
recurring challenge for him in this
movie I cannot wait to explore this
movie on a deeper thematic level because
as many of you know that the first
Guardians of the Galaxy film is my
favorite MCU film and very soon you are
about to hear about a huge new thing
that new rockstars is going to launch
that makes me very excited that this
film is coming in the next year I can't
say too much about it yet but you will
know soon and I have very big plans for
Guardians volume 3 in particular you can
follow me on Tick Tock Hive Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
that was an awesome mix volume Easter
eggs man there was a good amount there
very excited for this movie
what are these jokes
you know I just I wanted to end on an
ironic note because you know me man I'm
too cool for anything I don't anticipate
stuff
it's funny it wasn't a joke but then it
became a joke
and now it's getting better
you're the best jokes to relax
Tyler Hague my friend learning about
Rocket Raccoon and him having a soul
mate it's made me go you know what this
year what I want to do for 2023 is first
cut you open see what's inside do some
genetic experiments on you and then I'm
gonna find you a woman we're gonna Bride
of Frankenstein this [ __ ] and I'm gonna
make sure that she loves you We're Not
Gonna Write a Frankenstein fail force
that look we're gonna make sure this
woman is committed to you despite
whatever nuts and bolts are sticking out
of your neck and head she's gonna love
you yes or who you are on the inside
which will be my creation so really
she's loving me so this is really like a
weird cyclical process that's really
more about validating myself in the end
by having you find not true love but a
version of love that will feel like true
love yeah so what's the difference
really really I mean you know everything
your feelings come and go you know and
sort of desires and whatever life is
just a big black hole of depression at
the end of the day so that's true what
I'm trying to get at Tyler is I want to
give this as a gift to you this year
it's that way you find the well you
wouldn't do any of the final defining
for you it's a real easy process to get
this done believe it or not so I've got
done it before so I will I will provide
you with the woman but if you request a
man I could do a man too
um but it's been a group you just let me
know men are a little bit harder to
capture uh but I don't know actually
these days sometimes it looks better off
Tyler just let me know what your
preference is option a option b b for
boy a for woman and uh let's just go
from there it's right here
foreign